okay where do I peek seriously I'm
emptying it right now
this is happening you guys this is so
mortifying nobody Judge Me Kendall
Jenner has a full-blown panic attack on
the way to the Met Gala and he's in an
ice bucket oh my God just be cool it's
fine the whole thing goes down on the
latest episode of Hulu's the Kardashians
cameras follow the model as she makes
her way to the big NYC Fashion Event in
a sprinter van rocking a dramatic black
dress from Prada on top of being
completely out of breath thinking I'm
missing the carpet I think I just like
started to panic and honestly just
needed air I'm Legit gonna cry it's fine
candle has been open about her anxiety
in the past and back in April she
explained to E.T why she sets boundaries
when it comes to the show from a really
young age I think both Kylie and I kind
of knew what we wanted to keep off the
show or what we wanted to keep to
ourselves and again our boundaries may
change one day depending on the
situation but yeah sure Kenny has
boundaries but not when it comes to
peeing in a bucket
forever has to deal with my pee later
I'm so sorry it happens all the time can
we sell it
it's filled it's gonna happen but
someone needs to turn on music because I
can't let you guys listen to me oh my
God I got this yeah after Kendall's
nerve subsided she peed in Prada
in a bucket inside the van
[Applause]
one of the most glamorous nights yeah in
fashion
okay best decision I ever made because I
don't know what I would have done when I
got inside
it's really going in the street
aren't you is anyone else getting major
bridesmaids vibes it happened it
happened
well you're really doing it aren't you
Kendall Jenners you're in Sample here we
go
there's feet on my feet
right it's a fun story on my foot you
never would have known all that went
down on the way to the Mets based on how
Gorge Kendall looked on those stairs
which is exactly why Kendall's Mama Kris
Jenner loves their new series the
episodes are more a little bit
documentary style and I think that you
have a real insight into what the girls
are doing not only you know what you see
in the press or whatever but what's
really happening behind the scenes
before you would see little Snippets of
something and now I think the episodes
are um you know Fuller of content that
shows the whole story
[Music]
foreign